amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous
regardez et maintenant l'émission qui
revient avec plaisir et avec vous sur
l'actualité politique de la semaine vous
connaissez le principe hashtag et
maintenant si vous souhaitez réagir
week-end de la Pentecôte oblige sur ce
plateau aujourd'hui uniquement des
esprits sains des apôtres de la juste
analyse et de la bonne humeur on a
sélectionné les meilleurs pour vous
Nathalie segun bonjour c'est une
première pour vous ravi de vous
accueillir vous êtes journaliste et
éditorialiste à l'opinion à côté de vous
Alexis Lacroix bonjour également une
première vous êtes essayiste et
directeur du journal actualité juive
vous avez signé la République assassinée
c'est aux éditions du Cerf on accueille
une habituée aussi sur ce plateau Sophie
de Ravinel heureuse d'être là
journaliste politique au Figaro merci
d'être avec nous et Pascal Perrineau
également un habitué professeur des
universités à Sciences Po Paris bonjour
je renvoie votre dernier livre le
populisme c'est paru aux éditions puff
dans cette émission on se demandera si
Marine Le Pen est toujours l'ami de la
Russie si a quand même encore quelques
amis alors qu'il reconnaît désormais
l'efficacité du vaccin contre le covid
on verra si la France est malade et si
le député insoumis François Ruffin sera
son guérisseur en 2027 merci président
Larcher mais d'abord ce duel d'un côté
le gouvernement de l'autre les
républicains cette semaine ils se sont
livrés une bataille rangée autour du
thème de l'immigration la droite a lancé
l'offensive le week-end dernier avec une
série de propositions chocs sur
lesquelles on reviendra puis en milieu
de semaine le gouvernement a tenté de
riposter écouter oui il y a trop
d'immigrés aujourd'hui en France par
rapport à notre capacité
d'assimilation de ces étrangers on le
voit sur l'insécurité c'est le ministre
de l'Intérieur lui-même qui a fait le
lien entre immigration et délinquance
dans les transports en commun 10 de
France plus de 90% des vols 93% même
sont commis par des étrangers vous
proposez pour certaines dispositions de
sortir de la convention de de 1951 de
sortir des traités de l'Union européenne
de sortir du Conseil de l'Europe de
sortir de la CEDH et si c'est tout à
fait vrai c'est une question importante
que ce frexit migratoire il faut
évidemment que nous puissions échanger
sur les propositions constitutionnelles
mais avouer que c'est ici nous faisons
un projet de ordinaire je veux redire
que à la demande de la première ministre
j'ai entrepris des négociations les
discussions avec le groupe LR du Sénat
avec les centrist avec tous les autres
groupes qui le souhaitent bien
évidemment pour je l'espère à l'automne
discuter de ce texte arrêté d'en parler
et de commencer d'être concret comme
vous l'a proposé le gouvernement Pascal
pourquoi ce duel autour de l'immigration
quel est l'enjeu politique aujourd'hui
si vous voulez l'enjeu il n'est pas
nouveau
l'importance de cette question de
l'immigration dans l'opinion publique
c'est quelque chose que l'on retrouve
tout au long des enquêtes depuis plus
d'une décennie alors les Français ils
ont l'impression en effet on entendait
le présidentiotique
cioti partage le sentiment dominant des
Français dans une enquête qui vient de
paraître 60% des Français considèrent
qu'il y a trop d'immigrés en France
alors ensuite quand on regarde en détail
sur les solutions à apporter à cette
question immigrée les solutions varient
mais les Français ont l'impression tout
de même que que ce soit la gauche ou la
droite qu'il n'y a pas de politique
d'immigration en France qu'on en change
au gré qu'on fait
je sais plus combien c'est tous les 5-6
ans quelque chose comme ça qu'on fait
des réformes et que la question immigrée
et les problèmes que peut poser ne sont
pas véritablement
abordés d'où le voyage vous avez vu
régulier maintenant aussi bien du côté
que de l'opposition le voyage au
Danemark parce que au Danemark alors on
pourra en parler je le prononce pas sur
le fond mais au Danemark ils ont mis en
place une coalition de centre gauche ils
ont mis en place une vraie politique
d'immigration qui a satisfait l'opinion
puisque l'opinion danoise a énormément
évolué sur la question
regarde les propositions du parti LR en
matière des migrations les LR qui
proposent une révision de la
Constitution l'organisation d'un
référendum sur l'immigration la
possibilité de déroger au traités
européen l'inscription du principe
d'assimilation dans la Constitution la
mise en place de quota le rétablissement
du délit de séjour clandestins et la
double peine le remplacement de l'aide
médicale d'État par une aide médicale
d'urgence et ou encore la restriction du
droit du sol l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est
qui est le plus crédible ou qui est le
plus ferme Alexis je crois que
très bien résumé le tableau général de
d'ensemble il y a en France en France
pas seulement à droite le désir
l'attente d'un retour on peut dire d'une
reconquête si l'on veut du politique
comme tel or le politique c'est de
décider qu'on le veuille ou non de notre
destin comme nation comme collectivité
comme commun républicain ça c'est la le
tableau de l'ensemble je suis
entièrement d'accord avec le diagnostic
et le constat de Pascal maintenant
comment ces formations le décline ça
c'est intéressant Darmanin c'est un
homme respectable mais il est à
l'intérieur du cadre de l'Union
européenne telle qu'elle existe il vient
de le rappeler d'ailleurs très éloque
maintenant faut pas se leurrer ce cadre
limite la capacité à la fois du
législateur français mais aussi d'un
responsable public français notamment du
président de la République de son
gouvernement a véritablement géré les
flux migratoires ne nous le rend pas et
je ne et ce n'est pas un neurosceptique
qui vous dit cela
vous avez un LR qui est manifestement en
train de faire du buissonisme sans
buisson c'est à dire qui est influencé
il faut dire les choses clairement par
un modèle il libéral quand on parle du
modèle libéral on parle notamment de la
Hongrie de Victor Orban mais aussi par
exemple de la coalition de la nouvelle
coalition des droites qui s'est mise en
place en Italie sous la houlette de
Georges jamais l'ONU et donc
effectivement ces gens-là à tort ou à
raison je ne juge pas je décris sont
inspirés par l'idée qu'il faut
contourner les juridictions européennes
notamment la Cour européenne des droits
de l'homme afin de mieux maîtriser les
mouvements migratoires maintenant je
vais vous dire le fond de ma conviction
alors rapidement comme ça en réalité ça
excite beaucoup les journalistes ça nous
excite à juste titre ce match elle a
l'air d'armanin mais à mon avis ces
matchs nul part avant pourquoi car il
s'agit dans un cas comme dans l'autre de
posture la posture de Darmanin je joue
je monte mes muscles je joue au ministre
de l'Intérieur préfère qui en fait ne
fait pas grand chose et par ailleurs la
posture de LR qui se la joue plus
buissons plus Patrick Buisson que moi tu
meurs et qui à l'arrivée ne feront pas
grand chose s'il revenait un jour aux
responsables vous êtes d'accord on est
dans la posture des deux côtés du côté
du gouvernement et du côté LR en matière
d'immigration aujourd'hui oui mais enfin
c'est la base de la politique on est
d'abord dans des postures avant de
d'engager le travail de fond là le
travail de fond a pas été engagé et
c'est une bataille de posture comme
toujours sur tous les sujets
aussi en politique bien sûr elles
arrivent en général après et après un
gros travail de fond là on y est pas là
c'est un coût politique avant toute
chose elle est refait son unité sur
cette ligne très dure qui est
effectivement celle de Patrick Buisson
et qui surtout lui permet de de
reconquérir peut-être des voix sur le RN
c'est de la tactique après moi je trouve
que finalement si on parle de coups
politiques elle n'a pas grand chose à
perdre dans cette histoire parce que ils
sont dans leur rôle ils sont
l'opposition ils font des propositions
Macron avait dit les oppositions ne font
jamais de ils en font pour une fois ils
refont l'unité là-dessus et si il piège
la majorité parce que si la majorité ne
vient pas sur leur position
qui sont soutenus par les Français comme
Pascal
a expliqué
elle sera accusée de vouloir rien faire
en matière d'immigration donc elle met y
mettre quand même l'exécutif en
difficulté ce qui est une première
depuis le début de ce quinquennat c'est
un piège qui est tendu aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron et au gouvernement ses
propositions à l'heure qu'on a vu oui
c'est un piège mais surtout pour revenir
sur ce qu'on dit mais de confrères et
Pascal perinaut de façon très
intelligente je n'ai pas grand chose à
rajouter mais effectivement c'est une
question de posture effectivement c'est
une question politique effectivement
c'est une question sociologique et de
rapport que les Français entretiennent
avec des angoisses dont nous aurons sans
doute l'occasion de parler au cours de
cette émission d'ailleurs relevé par le
Président de la République sur la
décibilisation mais je crois aussi que
c'est un constat de difficulté
d'impossibilité à agir qui rend encore
plus ce débat sur l'immigration
compliquées à la fois au niveau européen
évidemment parce que nous sommes sous la
contrainte non pas forcément des seules
règles européennes mais des avis
divergents qui existent au sein de la
Communauté européenne très bien relevée
par Alexis Lacroix en parlant de la
Hongrie parce qu'il y a évidemment entre
la Hongrie le Danemark l'Allemagne la
France des positions très différentes et
l'Italie évidemment mais parce qu'il y a
aussi des impossibilités liées tout
simplement aux relations que la France
entretient avec les pays de départ de
ces migration on le voit sur le dossier
des occultés F qui sont ces obligations
peut-être le territoire français et qui
sont liés évidemment à la bonne volonté
des pays de départ et qu'est-ce que le
sujet dit il dit toute la difficulté
géopolitique de ce dossier et
l'impossibilité pour les politiques qui
ne travaillent que sur le chant français
de trouver des solutions qui puissent
être applicables si je résume à ce que
ce que j'entends sur ce plateau c'est
que là c'est du vent ce qu'on entend
depuis une semaine c'est des postures de
la com et c'est une applicable attendez
ne surinterprétez jamais ce que nous
disons alors et je me permets de ce
conseil
il y a de la posture c'est ce que nous
avons dit avec Nathalie bien sûr la
politique en étant parti composé mais il
y a aussi le désir plus plus à fond si
vous voulez de renouer avec un logiciel
cohérent et là je pense notamment à LR
le ministre de l'Intérieur il fait ce
qu'il peut dans un cadre où
effectivement la France n'est pas
maîtresse des flux migratoires pour
plein de raisons que nous avons évoqué
avec Pascal maintenant elle est cherche
à reconstruire une matrice sur tous les
sujets que nous appelons dans notre
jargon de journaliste politique le
régalien le régalien c'est à dire bien
sûr le contrôle est flux migratoire mais
aussi la sécurité l'École etc l'hôpital
bon ils cherchent à reconstruire une
matrice ils sont en train de rechercher
quelque chose disons clairement les
choses il faut pas faire de procès
d'attention absurde et antifascistes
absurdes des pavloviens qui ce qui
serait du côté d'une forme de gaullisme
un peu ferme un ferme inspirez nos
France avait la main ça se saurait
à notre ami mais il y a une sincérité
aussi attention il n'y a pas que de la
posture il y a la recherche d'un
gaullisme ferme le seul problème qu'ils
ont là voilà je disais les choses
clairement ce créneau là de du gaullisme
ferme très ferme en matière migratoire
notamment et sur le régalien bah il est
à reconquête donc c'est évidemment et
donc à terme ils ont un problème aussi
parce que ces idées là sont déjà
développées
réinvestissement de cette matrice en
tout cas et donc effectivement de toute
façon à terme c'est un espace qui est
largement occupé donc on pense par
ailleurs de ces programmes mais on
décrit de réel parce que l'immigration
le thème de l'immigration c'est la
planche de salut pour partir LR
aujourd'hui c'est le seul moyen de
sortir si la tête de l'eau entre
guillemets
le détestable épisode
des positions sur la réforme des
retraites où c'était véritablement le
chaos absolu en interne on a
l'impression que ce parti ne contrôlait
plus rien a commencé par ses élus ce qui
est gênant qui avait un LR au Sénat LR à
l'Assemblée nationale qui en avait
plusieurs d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée
nationale bon ça ne pouvait pas durer
longtemps et là c'est vrai que sur
l'immigration c'est véritablement une
position unie on a vu Michel Barnier en
effet aux côtés d'érection dans le
voyage qui vient d'être fait au Danemark
donc il recréer une unité alors ensuite
en effet il y a une si vous me en été
une concurrence dans l'espace des
droites sur ce thème qui est très fort
et on le voit dans l'enquête par sondage
que je citais celle qui reste comme
étant la plus crédible sur la question
migratoire c'est Marine Le Pen et de
très loin de très loin par rapport à
Zemmour de très loin par rapport à les
électeurs préféreraient l'original à la
copie sachant que Gérald Darmanin
et dans les faits les urnes le montrent
mais c'est vrai que Gérald Darmanin sur
ce sujet là parvient à s'imposer tout de
même ce qui doit effectivement susciter
quelques tensions du côté de reconquête
qui veut habiter ce thème du gaullisme
et des lrche qui normalement le thème
devrait être très habituellement traité
de Bussy Patrick Buisson c'était quoi
son pari avec Sarko c'était tu restes
comme tu es mais tu vas faire semblant
d'être ferme et de toute façon à terme
je réponds à Pascal qui a parfaitement
raison à terme lui susurait buisson
quand il le conseillait
tu gagneras sur le rassemblement
national qui frappeur ben aujourd'hui on
peut se poser la question est-ce que ça
marche est-ce que réellement les
Français vont préférer la copie pirate
entre guillemets d'une idéologie de
fermeté à l'original et bien c'est pas
sûr peut-être qu'un jour effectivement
l'original peut l'emporter je suis
d'accord à force de jouer en quelque
sorte à l'échalote de la triangulation
on se comprend il y a le risque que un
jour que ce soit l'original qui soit
préférée une loi est annoncée pour
l'automne comment ça va se terminer
Nathalie très concrètement ça va être
négociation entre le gouvernement et les
LR dans l'idéal oui
effectivement mais le problème c'est que
on parle beaucoup de Gérald Darmanin là
sur ce plateau mais il est il a aussi un
autre problème en dehors du droit
européen c'est la majorité la majorité
macroniste n'est pas du tout favorable à
aller sur le terrain à se rapprocher de
l'air à laisser tomber la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papiers dans les
métiers en tension
à accepter
des propositions de LR qui leur
paraissent totalement aberrantes comme
bon évidemment
le concept d'assimilation dans la
Constitution le fait de pouvoir déroger
au droit européen tout ça c'est
inacceptable donc ils sont partis très
loin ils sont partis de très loin les LR
se qu'on sait pas c'est si c'est une
position dure pour arriver à trouver un
compromis ou
elle se rapprocher de la majorité mais
j'ai du mal à penser que la majorité
elle va pouvoir se rapprocher de LR on
avance François Ruffin muscle son jeu le
député insoumis de la Somme à lancer un
appel sur les réseaux sociaux ça
entreprise est en pleine expansion il
est en plein recrutement il cherche
actuellement des collaborateurs écoutez
il est évident maintenant que j'ai opéré
un changement de division tu vois c'est
si tu montes de la en étant le même dans
la division supérieure on pourrait jouer
en Champions League mais que tes parents
d'une équipe autour de toi assez dense
assez solide bah tu vas perdre tous tes
matchs je sens combien il y a
une sympathie pour ce que j'essaye de
faire comment il y a des bonnes volontés
mais qu'aujourd'hui je suis incapable de
les cristalliser je suis incapable de
les organiser parce que j'ai pas un
organisateur qui autour de moi opère ça
donc si vous voulez m'aider nous aider à
franchir cette étape vos choux on a
besoin de vous et de vos sous Sophie
vous êtes docteur s nupes expliquez-nous
ce que ce qu'on vient d'entendre c'est
quoi c'est il veut se présenter comme le
candidat de la gauche en 2027 c'est pas
très clair parce que je pense que
lui-même n'est pas complètement clair il
y a quelque chose un peu chez lui de
d'indécis surtout moi ce qui m'a frappé
alors déjà pour nos auditeurs pour être
très clair Jean-Luc Mélenchon mi-avril
lui a mis le pied à l'étrier à
l'occasion d'un sondage de cluster 17 km
le lendemain François Ruffin au lieu de
dire oui oui je me prépare lui dit non
non c'est pas le moment parce que c'est
la réforme des retraites etc donc un peu
voilà un bal de un bal des citations
mais un mois plutôt sur le média vidéo
combiné François Ruffin avait dit s'il
faut relever le drapeau je le ferai pour
les classes populaires par présenté etc
donc objectivement il se prépare pour
être candidat il ne sait pas si les
conditions vont être là pour pouvoir
aller oublier
sa formation politique indépendante des
insoumis je vais vous donner la parole à
XI Lacroix indépendante des insoumis
faire des là je vous en prie je veux
surtout pas vous laver
et du coup pour sa formation politique
indépendante des insoumis qui s'appelle
Picardie debout ça c'est le cadre une
réflexion
il est très seul dans sa cuisine il est
très seul dans sa cuisine et moi ça
m'évoque sa solitude et sa difficulté à
agréger autour de lui j'ai des
difficultés j'ai discuté avec des
anciens collaborateurs qui ont été mal
payés qui ont été extrêmement exploités
pour bosser comme des fous et c'est vrai
que François Ruffin travaille beaucoup
lui aussi il a du mal à agréger et une
information que ce tour de table n'a
peut-être pas hier enfin disons cette
fin de semaine jeudi à l'Assemblée
nationale dans le cadre d'un débat sur
la Boétie il y a eu un débat très dur
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur la question
justement du traitement des classes
populaires par la gauche radicale et ce
débat là est très fort chez les insoumis
parce que c'était un débat intra
insoumis et que François Ruffin pour
l'instant est très isolé Pascal
présentez-nous François Ruffin parce que
c'est pas quelqu'un qui est très connu
forcément très connu des Français c'est
un peu ce que dit Sophie c'est d'un côté
il y a une gauche proche des classes
populaires et peut-être Mélenchon c'est
une gauche je sais pas comment on
pourrait le définir moins proche des
couches populaires c'est comme ça qu'on
pourrait résumer ces deux lignes
aujourd'hui je peux juste dire un tout
petit mot François Ruffin il est plus
dans la défense des sous-préfectures du
point de vue territorial quand Jean-Luc
Mélenchon compte plus sur l'abstention
des quartiers populaires et c'est juste
ce petit mot là Pascal si vous voulez
Ruffin c'est un homme de la société
civile rentrée en politique vous allez
me dire ce n'est pas tout à fait le
premier mais ça marque profondément son
style c'est-à-dire que c'est un homme
qui a un problème de rapport avec les
appareils que ces appareils soient d'un
nouveau type ce mouvement gazeux qui est
défi ou des parties plus traditionnelles
comme le PS ou LR donc il a et on le
voit un véritable problème
avec et les filles est-ce qu'il peut
faire par exemple une campagne contre
les filles ou même à côté des défis je
ne crois pas je ne crois pas il n'a
certainement pas les moyens pour
inventer en même en quelques années un
mouvement qui soit un mouvement à sa
main comme avait pu le faire Emmanuel
Macron avec la République en marche
parce qu'il y avait des hommes qui
étaient en effet un peu extérieur au
système Ruffin encore bien plus
qu'Emmanuel Macron et qui voilà avait
été créé par une stratégie de disruption
un appareil je ne crois pas que Ruffin
en a la capacité et je crois cru fin et
en plus ça sur le fond porteur d'une
stratégie qui est une vraie stratégie de
création d'un populisme de gauche que ne
partage pas la majorité je vais quand
même vous montrer ce sondage avec si je
vous donne la parole ce sondage et là
qui en date de fin avril pour les
présidentielles 2027 53% des électeurs
de gauche estiment que François Ruffin
serait le meilleur candidat alors
réaction évidemment pascalade a raison
la politique c'est aussi les appareils
personne ici n'est débile ne fait
l'impasse merci non mais sur cette
dimension on est bien d'accord on a tous
lu Robert Michaels sur les partis
politiques très bien ok pas tous pas
tous
politique très bien ok donc on ne peut
gagner une présidentielle que si on a
derrière soi peu ouprou un appareil même
récent comme les terres en marche au
moment de sa création par le président
Macron maintenant attention le populisme
rival qui est celui de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon aujourd'hui excède une grande
partie de la gauche d'ailleurs on le
voit bien il y a des réveils alors vous
allez me dire c'est la famille sociale
démocrate très bien il y a quand même
des réveils importants en termes
d'opinion de gens qui se sentent
orphelins d'une gauche républicaine
laïque ferme sur la simulation et qui ne
transige pas avec toute forme de ce
qu'on appelle j'aime pas tellement le
mot mais disons d'islamo gauchisme donc
le problème de Mélenchon à terme c'est
que qu'on le veuille ou non pour des
raisons là pour le coup tactique il a
fait alliance il a fait alliance avec
cette zone là de la gauche rue fin c'est
du populisme certes c'est les c'est la
France périphérique oui c'est les
sous-préfectures bien sûr mais c'est
plus au barycentre de ce qui était
historiquement
la gauche française c'est-à-dire une
gauche de province en partie gérondine
d'ailleurs qui a porté les énergies les
espoirs depuis la Troisième République
en réalité et là je complète le tableau
qui a été donné par nos amis Rufin est
un en partie le continuateur d'une forme
de populisme sauf de la Troisième
République si on ne voit pas ça on ne
voit pas sa stratégie et donc c'est pour
ça qu'elle est dirigée sur le plan des
idées et pas seulement de l'appareil
contre ce que fait actuellement Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui est une gauchisation à
terme tout à fait suicidaire de LFI en
réalité
sur le plan si vous voulez de la limite
de la France je termine juste rapidement
ouais très rapidement ce plan de l'idée
de la France il y a deux idées de la
France concurrentes Jean-Luc Mélenchon
se résout en quelque sorte à ce qu'il
appelle joliment avec Edward glissant la
créolisation de l'identité française
mais paru fin Ruffin il veut réinventer
le logiciel d'une forme de
social-démocratie républicaine
anticapitaliste il y a beaucoup de
Français ne nous le rend pas sur le plan
sociologique qui sont les enseignants
par exemple de province justement qui
sont orphelins de cette sociologie là et
qui aimerait qu'elle soit à nouveau
incarnée politique et François Ruffin
aimerait peut-être être le candidat de
l'avion en 2027 Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
tweet mi-avril en disant qu'il est prêt
ça veut dire quoi Jean-Luc Mélenchon il
est vraiment prêt à laisser la place à
François Ruffin ou est-ce que là on est
encore dans la comédie bon vas-y pas mon
petit part on est à 4 ans des élections
tu peux y aller à casser les dents sur
l'opinion je pense pas du tout qu'il
soit prêt je pense que il est même très
près à la une nouvelle présidentielle il
en a déjà trois dans les temps
il en a trois dans les pattes il a une
expérience
que n'apparu fin évidemment
il est pas prêt je pense qu'il se sent
en pleine forme non ça c'est pas du tout
ce que je pense
le problème c'est que pour Ruffin c'est
que Mélenchon il tient la boutique et
alors sur les deux lignes Mélenchon lui
il veut renverser la table
la Ruffin le dit dans cette vidéo Ruffin
est beaucoup plus dans un une dans
l'idée d'une altern de réussir une
alternance à gauche ce qui est pas du
tout le cas de Mélenchon Mélenchon il
veut pas le pouvoir à mon avis
il ne veut pas le pouvoir enfin je n'y
crois pas un instant et il veut le
Premier ministre
oui le pouvoir est pas Matignon on le
voit à tous les jours le alors bon
Ruffin est beaucoup plus rassembleur il
rassemble il est compatible avec le PS
il est compatible du fait de ce discours
social-démocrate avec les écolos et si à
mon avis le PS et les Verts restent dans
la nuit passe aujourd'hui et veulent une
liste commune aux européennes en tout
cas pour le PS c'est qu'ils veulent
peser sur le choix du candidat en 2027
donc c'est un élément à ne pas négliger
mais je ne crois pas du tout aux chances
de Rufin isolé à la fille d'y arriver
Sophie vous êtes plus optimiste alors je
suis plus pragmatique si je peux me
permettre je pense qu'en fait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon n'a pas une idée claire
évidemment que s'il peut y aller il ira
s'il est assez en forme physique il ira
il est quand même un peu déjà
aujourd'hui et surtout il y a pour
nuancer même si je partage absolument
votre propos Nathalie il y a chez
Jean-Luc Mélenchon cette idée que il
pourrait ne pas pouvoir y aller et que
il voulait évidemment que ce soit Adrien
katnaste qui prennent sa suite qui est
tombé pour violence conjugale et je
pense qu'il va quand même si François
Ruffin parvient à trouver son chemin
être obligé à un moment de venir le
soutenir même s'il ne partage pas
complètement son
champ idéologique Marine Le Pen est-elle
toujours l'ami de la Russie avant de
répondre petit flashback rappelez-vous
c'était il y a un peu plus d'un an pour
notre pays c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
parce que vous dépendez du pouvoir russe
et que vous dépendez de Monsieur Poutine
parce que quelques mois après avoir dit
cela Madame Le Pen vous avez contracté
un prêt en 2015 auprès d'une banque
russe et donc vous ne parlez pas à
d'autres dirigeants vous parlez à votre
banquier quand vous parlez de la Russie
c'est ça le problème Madame Le Pen voilà
depuis il y a eu la création d'une
commission d'enquête à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est le RN qui avait demandé
sa mise en place pour montrer que non le
parti ne dépend pas de Vladimir Poutine
cette semaine c'était au tour de Marine
Le Pen d'être entendu elle a répondu aux
accusations écoutez
je signe après avec une banque je signe
pas après que Vladimir Poutine
voilà sinon tous vous avez signé des
prêts avec Macron bah oui non mais
d'accord mais je veux dire ça voudrait
dire que quand on signe un prêt avec une
banque française on signe pas avec
l'accord d'Emmanuel Macron mais quand on
signe avec une banque qui est moitié de
check moitié russe obligatoirement c'est
en fait une signature que l'on est venu
non je signe avec une banque ça ne
m'engage absolument à rien et si ça
m'avait engagé à quelque chose monsieur
le Président je n'aurais pas signé ce
prêt c'est clair je ne l'aurais pas
signé Alexis est-ce que cette commission
d'enquête a permis de laver les soupçons
qui entourent Marine Le Pen et son lien
supposé avec la lumière Poutine alors il
faut toujours faire preuve d'un
partialité dans le commentaire politique
le plus possible elle est pas mauvaise
là bon on est d'accord et par ailleurs
ils ont excité d'un argument d'ailleurs
au moment même du débat face au
face-à-face avec le président de la
République avec Emmanuel Macron il avait
excité d'un argument ou rassemblement
national en disant nous sommes tournés
vers une banque russe au Tchèque car les
banques françaises nous avons O une fan
de nous recevoir à nos demandes de prêt
très bien le problème c'est qu'à mon
avis je vous dis très sincèrement elle
n'est pas très convaincante pour une
raison simple on ne peut pas mettre sur
le même plan même s'il y a de
l'interventionisme on peut pas
if on ne peut pas mettre sur le même
plan des régimes plus réalistes
constitutionnels comme ceux de la France
et
l'oligarchie en pleine dérive
autocratique terroriste et la Russie
doivent Vladimir Poutine et donc
évidemment qui a pas eu un coup de fil
de Poutine pour dire débloquer les fonds
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe mais
en revanche on sait bien qu'il y a une
sorte d'international poutinienne qui
tend en Europe notamment à favoriser les
parties qui sont des parties violemment
anti-européens et donc effectivement
logiquement Marine Le Pen ce qui
n'enlève rien par ailleurs à sa
sincérité sur d'autres plans nous ne
sommes pas en train de faire son procès
mais logiquement Marine Le Pen s'inscrit
dans cette configuration favorable de la
part des autorités russes qui ne veut
pas dire que le prêt a été accepté par
les hautes autorités du Kremlin bien sûr
que non mais c'est plutôt une sorte de
configuration de sympathie et d'affinité
élective en fait est-ce que vous avez
été convaincus par l'appréciation de
Marine Le Pen je l'ai pas suivi j'ai pas
suivi les quatre heures mais j'ai pas
l'impression d'une prise de distance
très nette vis-à-vis de la Russie de
Poutine dans cette audition et en même
temps je vois quand même plus d'habilité
et elle et je la trouve quand même plus
plus convaincante que par exemple
François Fillon sur son
compte après elle c'est quand même assez
habile de sa part d'aller devant cette
commission elle en avait jamais c'était
jamais exprimée là-dessus avant là elle
parle sous serment elle dit il y a pas
eu de contrepartie politique auprès avec
la Russie voilà contact elle met ce
sujet derrière elle en termes de
communication et honnêtement je pense
pas que ça lui soit très préjudiciable
voilà
Pascal vis-à-vis des électeur cette
audition était aussi importante pour
montrer finalement qu'elle n'est pas
liée il n'y a pas eu de contrepartie à
ce prêt octroyé par la Russie par une
banque russe c'est pas la première fois
dans l'histoire que des forces
politiques françaises ont des liens
financiers avec la Russie bien qu'elle
soit soviétique ou poste soviétique
bon elle a été sur le fond là quand on
l'écoute relativement convaincante même
si en effet le degré de dépendance des
banques russes par rapport au pouvoir
politique et certainement plus fort en
Russie que ne l'est le degré de
dépendance des banques françaises par
rapport au pouvoir politique ça c'est la
première remarque la deuxième remarque
c'est sur le fond et sur le fond il y a
des choses qui n'ont absolument pas
changé quant à la force des rapports
entre le rassemblement national et la
Russie c'est d'abord la position sur la
Crimée bien sûr sur la position sur la
Crimée elle persiste elle insiste et
elle signe la Crimée et ruse elle
accorde un crédit à ce référendum qui a
été organisé dans des conditions très
contestables en disant bah voilà c'est
le peuple de la Crimée qui a choisi
d'être russe très très rattaché à la
Russie
rattaché à la Russie bien donc ça ça
entretient tout de même c'est un premier
un premier symptôme d'un lien qui n'est
pas coupé le deuxième c'est dans la
longue période quand vous connaissez
bien l'histoire du Front National et du
rassemblement national ils ont toujours
eu et c'était Jean-Marie Le Pen le
premier une conception de l'Europe qui
considère que l'Europe qui s'arrête en
Pologne et en Hongrie c'est pas la bonne
Europe que la bonne Europe c'est
l'Europe de l'Atlantique à l'oral donc
il y a là une conception de l'Europe et
là dessus et la part rompu véritablement
avec son père c'est il y a toujours
cette idée que une véritable Europe et
bien c'est l'Europe qui va qui va
vous constatez aussi ce tropisme prorus
du côté du RN est-ce que c'est
préjudiciable parce que ça ne l'est pas
parce que elle l'a rappelé lors de son
audition effectivement elle a les
opinions qu'elle a et elle a assumé
finalement cette idée de pas vouloir
alors pas humilier parce que c'est la
formule d'Emmanuel Macron mais pas
vouloir froisser la Russie dans le
dossier ukrainien je pense comme des
élus cigognes que effectivement
vis-à-vis de son électorat ça n'aura
aucune incidence voire même ça peut les
conforter on est sur le dossier de
l'OTAN on est sur le dossier de la crise
ukrainienne évidemment qu'on est sur le
dossier de de Vladimir Poutine de son
influence de son action de son de ses
accusations
relatives à prix gaugine et des liens
avec des sociétés
post-mafieuses
criminelle dont les actions en Afrique
pourront être dénoncées
d'ailleurs mais surtout on est sur un
débat idéologique européen effectivement
que l'on peut ramener à celui de De
Gaulle et j'entends certains
responsables politiques y compris dans
la gauche radicale que je suis plus
précisément me dire écoutez moi je suis
sur la position du bervé de Rin et de
Dominique de Villepin sur les rapports
apaisés la réelle politique etc très
bien bon donc je pense que Marine Le Pen
comme d'ailleurs François Fillon on l'a
dit ils sont audition début mai c'était
les mêmes arguments d'une certaine façon
et c'était vraiment de dire écoutez il y
a une autre Russie que celle de Vladimir
Poutine la vie continue et je pense que
ça ceux des Français puis les
soutiennent ne seront pas choqués on va
jouer Sophie si vous voulez bien on
passe à la rubrique fake news ou pas je
vous donne une info quelque chose qui
ressemble à une info et vous me dites si
c'est vrai ou si c'est fait cette
annonce de Bruno Le Maire le
gouvernement a annoncé
ton face aux propriétaires de jet privé
pour réguler leur utilisation une
vignette critère a été annoncée je crois
que vous avez subi ça et Nathalie une
vignette critère l'idée est d'organiser
une circulation alternée entre les jets
privés fake news ou pas
fake news ça tient pas la route Sophie
je croyais que vous alliez me parler des
paquets de pâtes de la famille le Mayer
non non écoutez moi je dirais pas fake
news c'est une fake news c'est une fake
news
actuel direction les États-Unis où on
n'arrête pas l'innovation une nouvelle
application mobile veut faire mieux que
Hubert un nouveau service de voiture à
la demande a été lancé mais cette fois
les conducteurs seront munis d'armes à
feu les voitures seront contre elles
entièrement blindés vous connaissez bien
les États-Unis Pascal est-ce que ça vous
semble plausible
donc c'est une fake Alexis je tomberai à
dire aussi que c'est une fake mais en
même temps vous savez sur le terrain de
la dérégulation du port des armes à feu
parfois les États-Unis que j'aime on
réserve de très mauvaises surprises
c'est une vraie information
l'application s'appelle
entrepreneur spécialiste en sécurité
privée l'objectif c'est de rendre les
trajets plus safés on en vient à ce coup
d'éclat d'un militant écologiste à peine
une semaine après sa triste mort une
semaine après avoir pénétré dans le
royaume de Dieu Daniel c'est son nom
aurait éteint la lumière qui se trouvait
tout au bout du tunnel il souhaitait
rappeler par là qu'il faut éteindre les
ampoules quand on quitte une pièce et
c'est quand même pas beaucoup demander
nom de Dieu
je n'ai pas compris
qui est éteint la lumière au bout du
tunnel en arrivant au royaume des cieux
absolument et donc c'est une histoire de
vous savez c'est c'est mort imminente
expérience de mort imminente c'est ça
mais oui non mais bien sûr
vous êtes trop sérieuse Sophie allez
plus sérieux cette question notre
société est-elle malade de la violence
des agressions et événements dramatiques
se multiplient ces dernières semaines
qu'on trouve des infirmières des élus
des agents publics ce jeudi à Roubaix
Emmanuel Macron a rendu hommage à trois
policiers tués dans un accident le
conducteur était sous l'emprise de la
drogue
pour rendre hommage à leur destin
dire respect et affection à ceux qui
servent et protègent
et dénoncer les comportements
irresponsables qui tuent pour décrire la
France d'aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron a
utilisé cette semaine le terme de
décibilisation conseil des ministres il
aurait déclaré la chose suivante il faut
être un traitable sur le fond aucune
violence n'est légitime qu'elle soit
verbale ou contre les personnes il faut
travailler en profondeur pour contrer ce
processus de décibilisation pourquoi il
a choisi ce terme Alexis alors deux
choses très rapidement le procès fait
par une partie de la gauche je dis bien
une partie je suis nuancé moi sur le
mode il a repris le mot de Renaud Camus
qui est un auteur d'extrême droite c'est
absurde et je vais pouvoir parce que le
mot n'est pas à la propriété de Renault
Camus il a été utilisé de nombreuses
fois avant par des sociologues j'ai relu
pour cette émission
absolument des morceaux de la
civilisation des mœurs
c'est pas un fasciste c'est pas
l'extrême droite c'est la c'est un juif
allemand qui a ensuite été exilé qui a
dû quitter l'Allemagne en raison du n'a
rien à voir avec l'extrême droite que
montre-t-il que dans la cour française
au 10 au 16 au 15e au 16e au 17e siècle
tous ces petits nobliots de province qui
viennent vont réfréner leur pulsions
polir les mœurs et finalement civiliser
la France c'est ça la scie vilalisation
des mœurs selon Elias mais si la
civilisation des mœurs existent la
décibilisation existe aussi vous voyez
une société n'est pas figée dans le
temps sur une essence définitive et donc
quand Macron là il faut le défendre à
100% quand Macron dit des civilisations
il note qu'effectivement comme Freud en
son temps l'avait fait je suis désolé de
ces références et bien la civilisation
c'est une fine pellicule à la surface de
notre humanité et si nous n'y prenons
garde effectivement cette fine pellicule
peut être alors progressivement enlever
et donc nous ne sommes pas encore dans
la des civilisation en revanche voyons
bien pas d'accord je finis juste ma
phrase nous voyons bien que l'explosion
des violences de toutes sortes
contrairement à ce que disent les
sociologues les violences contre les
personnes et pas seulement contre les
biens c'est explosion là nous menace
effectivement d'un processus où il y
aurait une brutalisation progressive de
la société et cette brutalisation pas
besoin de faire de longs cours
d'histoire pour comprendre que
généralement elle est porteuse de
solutions extrémistes qui sont
extrêmement dangereuses en pleine des
civilisations deux invités sur ce
plateau ne sont pas d'accord c'est un
duel vous connaissez le principe d'un
côté Pascal de l'autre Sophie c'est un
duel au sommet vous avez 45 secondes
chacun Pascal vous allez me dire
pourquoi selon vous oui la France est en
pleine décibilisation je poursuis ce que
vient de dire Alexis ce processus de
civilisation de nos pratiques de nos
comportements c'est dû à deux choses les
gens intériorisent de plus en plus les
normes donc il y a pas besoin de mettre
un flic derrière chaque personne et puis
on les individus contrôlent de plus en
plus leur pulsions c'est vrai que ces
deux mécanismes se dérèglent ceux des
règles et les symptômes sont multiples
on a donné en effet la montée des actes
violents
des viols ça a augmenté depuis l'année
dernière les violences familiales les
vols avec violence la violence verbale
il suffit de sortir dans la rue la
violence verbale ne cesse d'exploser et
puis tout ce qui est j'allais dire les
mœurs d'interaction les rapports entre
hommes et femmes la courtoisie les
rapports entre enseignants et enseignés
je suis assez bien placé tout cela ça se
dégrade non pas du tout Sophie et bien
écoutez prenons un peu de hauteur
prenons un peu de distance de hauteur
parce que dans le temps je pense que la
France n'a jamais été aussi peu violente
nous sommes au 19e au 20e on parlait des
Apaches on parlait de l'encensagement de
la société avec les mêmes termes dans
une société où la moitié de la
population était un alphabète et où la
question de la violence culturelle était
tout de même beaucoup plus forte
beaucoup plus évidemment du point de vue
scientifique évidemment des conséquences
de la santé évidemment sur les relations
entre hommes et femmes jamais elles
n'ont été aussi bonnes qu'aujourd'hui il
faut le dire il pour le répéter et il
faut aussi essayer de voir en quoi cette
décibilisation répond aussi à une perte
d'influence de l'Europe au niveau
mondial et évidemment à une angoisse
d'une société habité par lui influence
des États-Unis et qui n'ont plus la même
évidemment influence
bontez qui Pascal ou Sophie vraiment mon
coeur balance contre les deux
je suis plutôt du côté de Sophie mais
donc la France ne traverse pas un
processus de décibilisation selon vous
Adrien danger effectivement
l'incivisme
s'observe tous les jours la violence etc
mais bon il y a une inquiétude du côté
d'Emmanuel Macron réel c'est un coup de
com encore une fois
la question pour moi qui est
intéressante c'est pourquoi il utilise
ce mot il est il est dans une période où
il cherche à renouer avec le sensible
comme disent les communicants autour de
lui et ils cherchent à mettre des mots
sur ce que ressentent les Français et le
monde révèle ce samedi un déjeuner à
l'Elysée qui a eu lieu autour de lui
avec des sociologues il y avait Jean
Viard il y avait Jérôme Fourquet il y
avait Laurent casseli et où ils ont
beaucoup parlé justement de la montée de
la violence de tous ces toutes ces
violences qui ont émaillé ces derniers
jours et d'ailleurs semaine et c'est
Jérôme Fourquet qui a utilisé le mot des
civilisations et dès le lendemain
Emmanuel Macron reprend ce mot tout
simplement parce que enfin il est je
pense pas il y a aucune référence à
l'extrême droite dans son esprit c'est
simplement mettre un mot sur ce qui est
ressenti et ok franchement alors si si
il y a un centriste parmi les
sociologues c'est bien Jérôme Fourquet
il est pas du tout suspect de connivence
de près Emmanuel Macron
n'est pas Naïs il y a peut-être un petit
peu de provocation il est aussi c'est
aussi quelqu'un de indicateurs et il
adore jouer avec ça après il faut bien
voir que Emmanuel Macron il est en
campagne enfin à mes yeux il est en
campagne depuis la fin des retraites
pour pour remonter déjà sa cote dans de
popularité qui est tombé extrêmement bas
et puis
pour ce à mon avis c'est très personnel
mais pour se préparer le jour où il est
obligé dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale
il faudra repartir au combat et et je
pense que l'anticipe il est sur le
terrain très souvent il devait aller
dans le Var jeudi au dernier moment il
change il va à Roubaix rendre hommage
aux trois policiers parce que il faut
montrer aux gens qui ont qui il faut les
rassurer il faut leur parler il faut
renouer le lien avec les Français tout
simplement ce chiffre qu'on va voir la
progression des violences envers les
élus plus 32% en 2022 Pascal comment
vous expliquer cette progression de la
violence notamment envers les élus mais
pas seulement par un processus alors une
utilisation des civilisations
pas un processus d'en sauvagement je
crois que dans ce processus mais je ne
suis pas si vous voulez opposer à ce
qu'a dit Sophie c'était le terme de
Gérald Darmanin
c'est qu'à 10 Sophie est vrai sur le
court et moyen terme je ne suis pas
d'accord sur le cours et moyen terme il
y a un processus de dérèglement de
dérèglement des comportements et des
attitudes les symptômes en sont
multiples et en particulier celui-là
parce que l'agression contre les mers
les mers ils existent depuis le 19e
siècle l'agression contre les mers à ce
niveau-là c'est un phénomène nouveau
c'est un phénomène nouveau et ça fait
partie des processus de décibilisation
c'est à dire maintenant des citoyens qui
n'ont plus aucune intériorisation des
normes qui ne contrôlent absolument plus
leur pulsion pour reprendre ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sans prennent à se
représentant de l'autorité publique qui
est le maire et qui est pourtant la
figure politique la vous aimez des
Français à 60% des Français disent
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont confiance dans
ces politiques-là ça veut bien dire qu'à
la base dans le corps social il y a un
dérèglement des comportements et des
systèmes d'attitude qui est très
préoccupant parce que à la fin des fins
ça se termine toujours par un recours à
une autorité extrêmement forte
je pense qu'il faut interroger la
responsabilité des politiques sur la
défiance vis-à-vis des institutions et
vis-à-vis de ce corps social justement
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron n'a pas une
responsabilité dans ce que vous appelez
effectivement c'est des civilisations à
court terme est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
depuis la crise des gilets jaunes mais
bien avant et François Hollande et
Nicolas Sarkozy et d'autres ont leur
responsabilité aussi sur le rapport des
collectivités avec les Français manuel
Macron et bien je m'interroge sur les
tensions que notre société traverse
évidemment sur la question des libertés
publiques particulièrement est-ce que
par exemple toutes ces tensions que l'on
voit vis-à-vis des maires ne sont pas
causés aussi par des interdits par des
usages et notamment on parle des drones
par exemple on parle des des droits à
manifester alors on peut s'interroger
dire oui il y a des abus oui il y a un
usage
beaucoup trop extensifs on a vu pendant
les retraites des mais est-ce que oui ou
non l'action des forces de l'ordre peut
être interrogée oui ou non est-ce que
l'action les interdictions de
manifestations peuvent être interrogées
on pense aux casseroles donc une
responsabilité du pouvoir dans ces dans
cette décibilisation dont parle Emmanuel
Macron Alexis là-dessus alors je
voudrais aller plus j'ai beaucoup
d'affection pour Sophie donc je ne la
renie pas sur ce plateau mais je suis je
suis en net des accords avec elle je
crois qu'il faut hiérarchiser
c'est-à-dire nous avons bien sûr des
stratégies du choc qui existent aussi
bien dans le capitalisme contemporain
que dans la politique contemporaine mais
là c'est ce n'est pas ce dont nous
parlons Nicolas Sarkozy quand il était
président a mis en place des stratégies
du choc c'est absolument évident avec
qui sont dans la parlé tout à l'heure
mais là c'est pas ça là c'est plutôt un
processus effectivement de brutalisation
progressive du rapport des Français
entre eux indépendamment de
l'intervention des hommes politiques et
donc je rejoins totalement Pascal et
quand on est responsable public là en
l'occurrence le président de la
République je suis d'accord avec
Nathalie aussi il est obligé de refléter
les affects des Français mais il faut
vivre dans une grotte pour ne pas voir
cette brutalisation et donc quand vous
êtes responsable politique vous gérez le
temps attendez je finis je finis je
finis je finis vous gérez le temps court
autrement dit vous êtes sur les critères
si on parle clairement d'un criminologue
comme Alain Bauer inquiet de
l'augmentation des violences à l'arme
blanche notamment depuis deux trois ans
et pas sur les critères de Stephen
Pinker qui a fait par ailleurs des très
beaux livres sur la baisse tendance de
la criminalité sur les deux derniers
siècles très bien et quand vous êtes
responsable public vous êtes dans le
temps court donc vous répondez au temps
court il n'y a il n'y a rien là
d'anormal de la part de Macron il est
absolument avant son rôle sur ce plan là
il est dans son rôle revoilà le
professeur à Raoul merci président chez
oui vous savez Raoul celui qui
considérait que le vaccin n'était pas la
bonne solution contre le covid et bien
trois ans plus tard il a un peu changé
écouter le
moi je n'ai pas de religion
thérapeutique j'essaie de trouver ce
qu'il y a de mieux on trouve aussi que
les gens qui sont vaccinés parmi les la
moitié chez qui nous avions toutes les
sur 15000 personnes sur qui nous avions
toutes les données meurt moins que ceux
qui ne sont pas vaccinés et ça c'est
vrai c'est-à-dire ça veut pas dire que
ça empêche la contagion il y avait pas
de raison que ça empêche pas contagieux
bon Pascal tout ça pour ça oui tout ça
pour ça en effet il y a un côté
reniement mais qui est plutôt
sympathique quand on s'est trompé il
faut pouvoir le dire quoique quand on
j'ai écouté moi l'ensemble de
l'interview voilà c'est un semi
reniement par exemple sur
l'hydroxyde chloroquine il continue il
continue à dire que voilà des
échantillons alors de quelques centaines
de personnes ont montré l'efficace de ce
traitement alors que bon faut se méfier
des références à la science mais
l'essentiel des scientifiques dit que
c'était vraiment un placebo
il peut changer d'avis finalement si je
peux me permettre et j'ai pas
l'impression que Monsieur Raoult était
un des plus opposants à la question des
vaccins c'était effectivement son
traitement hydroxychloroquine qui a
depuis février 2020 a été mise en avant
et je pense que là il y a on parlait du
rapport aux institutions je pense que là
nous serons d'accord à l'excès la croix
il y a en tout cas chez lui une
responsabilité dans la défiance
vis-à-vis des institutions et évidemment
vis-à-vis des sciences qui étaient en
appui des institutions sur le vaccin et
c'est là où je pense qu'il y a une
responsabilité et là je pense que
il
a il a creusé il a contribué et c'est là
où est sa responsabilité a creuser un
fossé dans notre société entre les
Français et les institutions dans ces
domaines bien spécifiques
des vaccins mais aussi des traitements
médicaux et du rapport à la science de
façon globale
Emmanuel Macron qui était voir le
professeur à 8 à Marseille alors il y a
une responsabilité des politiques et des
médias quand même parce que je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez mais quand il a
commencé à faire du tam-tam sur
l'hydroxy chloroquine c'était en continu
sur les chaînes d'information donc
ensuite les politiques cours derrière
les médias c'est comme ça et donc le
fait que Emmanuel Macron se rende
souvenez-vous on était tous stupéfaits
se rendent dans son institut à Marseille
sans annonce sans rien pour le
rencontrer sans prise de parole enfin
presque dans une espèce de semi
clandestine T qui a été révélé
évidemment mais on le sait toujours
quand le président se déplace mais ça
lui a donné un crédit enfin c'est
extrêmement c'était une prise de risque
bien sûr une prise de risque énorme
alors qu'il avait été il était au sein
du conseil scientifique qui avait été
mis en place par l'Elysée et il en était
sorti parce que par mésentente avec ses
confrères donc quand même enfin il y
avait quand même déjà un côté sulfureux
sur ce personnage ensuite renom Muselier
le président de la région Provence-Alpes
et une bonne partie de la classe
politique en paka qui qui l'a soutenu
qui a dit que ça marchait qui s'est
soigné à l'hydroxy chloroquine enfin les
politiques que là dedans on jouait
aussi contribuer à cette défiance des
Français vis-à-vis de la science et du
discours
avec vous non je suis d'accord sur le
chute totalement d'accord avec Nathalie
je suis d'accord bien sûr aussi avec mes
deux autres confrères sur sur la
responsabilité la parole de
responsabilité qui n'a pas été tenue par
Didier Raoult tout au long de cette
crise c'est la cause est entendue et
c'est d'ailleurs tout à fait louable de
sa part de reconnaître qu'il s'est
trompé sur l'efficacité des vaccins mais
en revanche je pense que si vous voulez
la
comment dire les positions
de la défense officielle par la parole
officielle on pense notamment au
ministre de la Santé qui était excellent
ce moment-là de la vaccination ont été
affaiblis par la découverte progressive
d'un élément que nous ne savions pas
aucun entre nous ne le savez y compris
les médecins spécialistes de ce domaine
d'immunologie de et de virologie c'était
que le vaccin ARN messager qui était
très pratiqué en France ultra pratiquée
sous la forme du Pfizer notamment avec
comme
avantage de sauver des vies c'est-à-dire
de sauver mais c'est ce que je veux je
suis en train de dire je sais pas avec
comme grand avantage de sauver des vies
et de nombreuses vies et de réduire
évidemment les symptômes liés à la
maladie que contractée à la suite du
covid-19 donc de nombreuses personnes
ont été sauvées par le vaccin en
revanche si un point qu'on a découvert
plus tard et qui sur un plan
psychologique a raisonné comme un
affaiblissement de cette position
vaccinale c'est qu'il y a eu un discours
qui a été tenu pendant un an et je pense
à tort mais la science encore une fois
vous savez l'assurance tatonne la
science avance en même temps j'allais
dire que les populations et donc dans un
premier temps on a tenu un discours et
personne n'est responsable selon lequel
le fait de se vacciner protégeait des
transmissions tes contaminations et des
transmissions et on a découvert ensuite
que ça n'était pas le cas et donc cela a
évidemment rétroagi psychologiquement et
donner sur le moment l'impression que
des gens comme Raoult était des super
prophètes ce qu'ils ne sont pas vous
voyez il faut il faut être équitable
c'est à dire que dans cette affaire je
crois qu'il y a eu malheureusement
beaucoup de passions dans un camp qui
était le camp de l'irrationalité
irrationalité anti-vaccinale mais il se
trouve qu'on a découvert dans un
deuxième temps que le vaccin aussi
efficace soit-il contre les formes
graves de protéger pas des transmissions
et des contaminations ça a été un
élément très important
via ruiné et je l'avais dit sur le
moment je suis pas médecin mais qui a
ruiné la légitimité j'allais dire
profilactique de quelque chose qui nous
a été imposé par le pouvoir qui était le
fameux passe vaccinal à partir du moment
oui je sais et je sais à partir du
moment où le vaccin ne prévient pas les
transmissions le Pass vaccinal n'avait
aucune efficacité qu'est-ce que
l'affaire out dit de la société dans
laquelle on vit le phénomène Raoul ça
veut dire que dans une société qu'on
présente souvent là aussi dans une
vision très linéaire du progrès de la
raison de la science il y a des limites
évidentes et qui viennent du coeur même
de ceux qui sont trop premier rang de la
population scientifique à savoir les
professeurs de médecine etc et c'est
vrai que le professeur Raoul à cet égard
a été en emblématique de ce mouvement où
tout de même une certaine
irrationalité était au cœur de ceux qui
se présentent comme étant les meilleurs
défenseurs de la rationalité
scientifique
je vous pose une question très simple
c'est le président qui a marqué
l'actualité de la semaine en bien ou en
mal vous commencez à Nathalie qui est
votre top de la semaine Yaël brune Pivet
président de l'Assemblée nationale qui
résiste courageusement
à la pression de ses amis macronistes
qui veulent absolument qu'elle déclarent
y recevable la
sur l'abrogation de la réforme des
retraites
elle elle ne veut pas elle s'est déjà
prononcée l'Assemblée le bureau de
l'Assemblée a déjà déclaré cette pupl
recevable elle ne veut pas revenir
là-dessus et voilà et elle a besoin
c'est le rapport de Jean Pisani Ferri
sur la transition écologique qui est
vraiment alors qui fait un flop
médiatique à mes yeux puisque il a été
balayé d'un revers de main par par le
gouvernement par la majorité
de fait peu de chances d'aboutir enfin
de mettre le gouvernement un peu de
chances de mettre en place les ce qui
est préconisé et qui est surtout très
pauvre qui est très peu créatif c'est à
dire que que nous propose gens de
l'endettement ou une hausse des impôts
c'est franchement
si vous pouvez très rapidement votre top
je vais être plus rapide cette fois-ci
alors mon top c'est le Sénat bravo au
Sénat sur la restitution oui oui bravo
c'est non on peut le dire à la haute
chambre sur la restitution donc des
biens juifs spolié pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale c'est très bien c'était
effectivement une cause très importante
dans mon journal d'ailleurs nous la
suivons par définition depuis longtemps
et là vraiment les sénateurs les
sénateurs étaient à la hauteur de leur
mission République et mon flow alors je
n'ai rien contre lui comme personne
encore une fois je suis pas un mec
hargneux je crois Bruno Le Maire notre
ministre de l'Économie je trouve qu'il
en fait oui Non Non mais il en fait
beaucoup sur le mode France des classes
moyennes et de des périphéries urbaines
je vous ai compris et donc effectivement
parler de ces entre guillemets problèmes
de fin de mois avec les quatre enfants à
nourrir c'est un flop non mais quand on
est Bruno Le Maire si vous voulez je ne
dis pas que il régissime je me dis
absolument à cela et quand on est Bruno
Le Maire ça ne peut faire que sourire
une ménagère de moins de 50 ans comme on
dit chez les sociologues qui habitent
Pithiviers ou le fin fond de la Creuse
et qui elle va être beaucoup plus de
difficultés au supermarché
alors le top c'est cocorico parce que je
dis merci la France par le biais du
front du fond nucléaire qui est allé à
la rescousse d'une PME à priori et ça
devrait se conclure stratégique en
matière
industrielle qui s'appelle Sogo et qui
mérite d'être défendu pour ne pas tomber
sous un fond américain et le flop et
bien écoutez moi non plus je n'ai rien
contre lui mais effectivement le
ministre de l'éducation qui est Papé
Ndiaye actuellement à Metz et qui était
obligé de cacher son déplacement aux
élus locaux qui a vu le maire
subrepticement deux heures hier soir
pour éviter les casseroles ça dit quand
même beaucoup des tensions évidemment la
même question que votre top qui est
votre femme vous avez 10 secondes pour
qui le top c'est comme Alexis en effet
cette loi votée à l'unanimité et qui
montre aussi indépendamment du sujet qui
était essentiel la capacité du Sénat au
l'Assemblée nationale ferait bien de
s'en inspirer et le flop j'ai oublié
parce que je suis un excellent
[Musique]
c'est vrai que là Hongrie régresse dans
le classement des démocraties au cœur de
l'Union européenne c'est un problème
pour l'ensemble de l'Union européenne
merci merci à tous les cas c'est la fin
de cette émission ça lui avoue derrière
votre écran mais dit dans l'oreillette
que vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
nous regarder voir à nous regarder
puisque vous pouvez bien évidemment
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre nouvelle plateforme public
sénat.fr merci à vous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine même jour même heure
et même endroit bye bye
[Musique]